these are the official check points herb
a province which surrounds Beijing
everyone coming in is screened but then
there are the unofficial check points
village after village here is ceiling
itself off against the coronavirus the
handwritten signs say no Outsiders
allowed in other places have taken more
structural measures literally walling
themselves in this is the screening
checkpoint our street along residents
aren't doing this on government orders
but off their own batch trying to
protect their home whatever else is
happening in the outside world
we're 600 miles away from Wuhan here but
this village is taking matters into
their own hands they are distrustful and
they fear coronavirus all across China
communities are sealing themselves off
they're scared because the death toll is
now more than 100 with more than four
and a half thousand confirmed cases of
novel coronavirus the vast majority are
in Hebei Province where the military
have been drafted in
and a public information campaign has
started with adverts playing across 50
Chinese cities
[Applause]
[Music]
in Wuhan in the night the cry went up
Wuhan and oil it means keep going hang
tough a cry of solidarity shouted out
the window in a city sealed off not to
stop the virus getting in but to stop it
getting out
[Applause]
elsewhere they were treating in another
fortified village in her Bay residents
were installing this Porter cabin as a
guardhouse
- you're using father just had a meal to
go to good food healthy little tongues
of water solution while your father
doesn't work the central government has
called for national unity in this crisis
instead people are bunkering down
breaking their bonds with the outside
world and with each other